we're not gonna lie
competition in this category wasn't
still Sony's redheaded handheld had a
bit of a lackluster year especially in
terms of big new releases that said each
of these games still did something
special enough to warrant a little
end-of-year recognition whether it was
delivering silly rhythmic joy or simply
standing out from all the other G RPGs
on the platform with its inviting
painterly aesthetic and distinctive
hereditary system which allows players
to spawn generation after generation of
demon fighting family members or as
sheikah tainted bloodlines managed to
distinguish itself from the veritable
horde of turn-based Japanese RPGs that
call Vita home instead of simply
leveling up a predetermined party
players actually manage an entire clan
over the course of several in-game
lifetimes teaching inexperienced youths
to fight disciplining rebellious
adolescents when necessary and guiding
hardened adults into glorious battle
turning combat into a family affair made
for an oddly compelling twist on an
already beloved formula which in turn
made or ashika one of Vitas most
memorable experiences this year while
Lost dimension couldn't quite muster the
same unusual appeal of aura chicest
reddit Airy hook it still managed to
join the notable JRPG Club by offering
its own unique twist within your 11
character party lurks a traitor and it's
up to you to flush them out by any means
necessary for the most part loss
dimension sticks to standard JRPG
conventions but forcing players to
consider the true allegiance of every
character actually elevated both the
combat and presentation as well as the
overall experience above an army of
sammy games we only hope the developers
include the same dastardly set up in a
slightly more well-rounded sequel
shifting genres but not regions
danganronpa another episode ultra
despair girls attached a super cool
subtitle - an intriguing third-person
action spin-off of the popular
danganronpa series though some of its
action-oriented mechanics felt a little
clumsy its Moody soundtrack created an
unforgettable atmosphere as ultra
despair girls tale of murder mystery and
intrigue unfolded across a series of
clever puzzles fans of the universe
should be floored by the story execution
and even newcomers will likely find
themselves hooked if they can see past
the mediocre shooting and dive deep into
the borderline disturbing youth
rebellion narrative of course if you
need a palate cleanser after all that
child on adult murder action there is
always the ultra charming persona 4
dancing all night the game unfortunately
fails on many
the narrative feels on fulfilling the
chaotic visuals occasionally hinder
gameplay and the music selection Falls a
bit short but it's hard not to love a
narrative driven rhythm game featuring
the biggest stars of the persona
universe we're just happy knowing this
game exists and we figured the game of
the Year awards might be a good time to
remind you to finally we have Olly Olly
- welcome to Hollywood which not only
won our hearts with a terrible pun but
also impressed us with its super stylish
side-scrolling approach to skateboarding
where Tony Hawk five disappointed in
every way imaginable this game succeeds
a deep bag of tricks and addicting
scoring system and a rapid pace that'll
keep you playing far longer than you
intended well we do wish the game had
done more to distinguish itself from the
original Olly Olly 2 is still the most
enjoyable rkt skating game since well
the early Tony Hawk titles vitas 2016 is
already looking brighter thanks to some
big announcements at this year's
PlayStation experience but these 5
titles were brave enough to keep the
torch lit and give the Vita faithful
something to celebrate in 2015 for that
and for their one-of-a-kind hooks we
salute them
you